[Musique]
et
à
bonjour je m'appelle valérie vial je
suis la dirigeante de la voile vac basé
à elancourt est créée en 2010
[Musique]
je suis maître voilier c'est à dire se
dit m voyez quand on a 15 ans
d'expérience donc je crée des voiles
quel que soit le bateau après je
m'occupe de l'intérieur du bateau et
tous les accessoires qui compte
constitue le bateau et puis après tout
ce qui est réparation de voile de
kitesurf de porsche en voile du char à
voile
tout ce qui est en bord de mer en règle
générale
à force de faire de la couture mais en
voile du coup j'ai bien apprécié ce que
la diversité des coutures et tout ce
qu'on peut faire et du coup j'ai créé ma
société y à pas par envie et puis par
passion
ce noël des produits phares et ben
d'abord je recycle beaucoup donc des
sacs des pochettes des des articles pour
la piscine c'est à dire les coussins
tout ce qui est cher longue mais
chilienne les poufs les tabourets ça
peut être beaucoup beaucoup de choses
comme ça
[Musique]
les résultats ne sont pas comme
d'habitude donc on verra les résultats
en fin d'année là il ya eu qu un ou deux
marchés de réaliser donc
les finances sont pas bonnes cette année
mais c'est pas un souci on attendra les
prochaines la voilerie survie à comines
encore y'a pas de problème
[Musique]
et